so on leachates um the way to do
blindfold chess without any like outside
help
is first you have to
uh go to preferences enable
it's under game behavior input moves
with keyboard
and then you'll get this little thing
and then you need the voice there's a
few things a few ways to enable voice
one is sound and then speech for this
i'm going to do
the plugin that i used previously and
we're gonna have
we're gonna have slightly unusual words
uh let me get the volume to be okay
okay so blindfold queen that's time
goodbye to chat and hello
to darkness so it's 10 10 plus 5
points rated 14 33 okay
um i'm gonna start with uh b6
um a classic hippo opening
horsey c3 yeah some of the piece names
are going to be a little bit messed up
but it shouldn't be too difficult to
keep track
okay d4 so most important thing is to
like
just keep track of the the position
e6 is very typical kind of
i don't even know what this is called
soon to be a hippo b6 has a
another name too horsey f3 it's white's
playing in very
um classical fashion
like if i had a queen i would play
bishop to b4 here but i don't have a
queen g6
so i'm playing g6 i'm going for the
traditional hippo
the goal is bishop g7 d6
i'll bring the knight c7 and d7 elegant
d3
off into the bishop
okay so let's play bishop g7 elephant g7
yeah white center is very well guarded
so there's no um
there's no media capture f4
okay so c7 is unguarded i'll play d6 g6
yeah usually c7 would be guarded by the
queen but not in that case
big daddy eats lady mesopotamia
oh the voices are actually very similar
poppety hopper t
hop okay
um wait what about mesopotamia
i'm playing knight d7 horsey d7 i think
eventually i would like to attack
on the queen side
these lights developed like all the
minor pieces the ships on d3 f4
knights on c3 f3 pawns in the center
so the thing about this kind of central
pawn formation
if white pushes either the e or the
d-pawn
d5 yeah so this is one example if d5 i
play e5
so basically whatever pawn white pushes
i push the other pawn to close down the
position
e5 and now we get some kind of king's
indian structure
where if i had a queen the queen would
not be so useful anyway so
this is what i want
now the bishop's attacks
elegant d2 okay
that's some progress let's play 97. e7
so now i have all my my minor pieces
developed
the slightly non non-threatening squares
all my minor pieces on the seventh rank
but
it's a start the center is closed
haven't traded anything so far
i'm actually not sure if i want to
castle kingside or queenside
i'm thinking queenside and then just
have some sharp
attacking position b4
yeah let's be brave hopper t hopper t
hopper t hopper t
hopper t hoppity hop popper t hopper t
just for all the hobbities
that's probably not the best decision
but now the rooks are connected and
the plan going forward is to pawn storm
something like
f5 f5 f4 g5 g4
you might probably have similar plans on
the queen side
horsey b5 oh okay i always play king v8
big daddy b8
c4 this is terrifying but
to make do with what i got
c4 so i could play a6
i think a6 is so productive though
oh c4 was played to enable queen a4 but
queen a4 then a6
so i'll play f5 f5
launching my own attack it's a very
typical
kind of king's indian
structure the pawns kind of split the
board in half
so it's all about who can attack
more effectively
there's some nice tension f5 supported
by
by the pawn and g6 and also the pawn
or also the the knight in e7
so the bishop's on d2 and lady a4 i was
expecting that so i'll play
a6 horsey c3
okay
i mean this is still really terrifying
the question is how do i how do i
progress
and not get crushed
it's actually not a simple question to
answer
um thinking
i'm probably gonna just have to weather
the the storm
either the pawn storm
maybe go for
something like bishop f6
you see what white wants to do to me
now bishop f6 idea is to eventually play
g5
and either sack the pawn
or just get the pawn to g4
in the meantime though i mean it's up to
white to
do something probably on the queen side
attack does feel a little bit slow
but if white tries to attack
in some like direct way it's it's gonna
complicate the position
so the hope is that it complicates the
position enough that
there's some way can go wrong
but it's also like it's becoming hard to
actually track everything um
but actually it's not too difficult
because uh the harmony actually makes
sense
like i haven't one nice kind of big pawn
island h7 g6 f5 e5
d6 c7 b6 a6
bishop's f6 lady c2 okay that's a very
good sign
so the queen retreats unprompted
um no the queen on c2 creates the
battery with the bishop against f5 pawn
i could i could take on e4 but that
allows knight e4
so i think this is prime time to play f4
f4
winning connect 4 c7 d6 e5 f4
and now now we get kind of the very
typical king's indian structure where
the
the plan is g5 g4
a fool a4
it said f4 because it doesn't know how
to pronounce a
that's slightly terrifying i'll probably
just have to ignore all of white's
menacing plans
let's play g4 or
g5 g5 the light's still on
h3 oh h3 okay
so h3 is a very ironic move h5
because on one hand h3
uh attempts to prevent g4 but ironically
it's going to make g4 stronger
because now once g4 is played there's
going to be the tension between the
pawns
and very likely f5
either the the g file or h file will
open
now it might not matter because a pawn
is
about to destroy my my hopes and dreams
um but okay just have to ignore it and
carry on g4 g4 time
so both pawn storms in full swing
horsey h2 that's a good sign
okay so
i mean i still very well understand the
overall structure
white has wait did white wing connect
four two because white has pawns on d4
c4 b4
i guess now a5 as well queen's on c2
thing is i don't think white has any
immediate threats
knights on h2
where am i trying to do a refresher
where my minor pieces are
my rook's on d8 so i think it makes a
ton of sense just to
to play a move like rook uh rook d
g8 rook d g8
and then create the tension on the g
file
and just hope that white doesn't
checkmate me
so i'm threatening i mean of course the
main thread is just to take on h3 and
then create the pin along the g
file some reason i keep thinking the
bishop's on e2 but it's on d3
it's important oh my bishop's on f6 too
i was thinking white could maybe try h4
but h4 i just take the pawn with the
bishop
that's a tricky position for white and
white could try to take
one elephant e1
okay so the rook's on f1 bishop on e1
queen on c2 so white's playing
quite passively
i mean yeah i can go through with this
gh3 g8
h3 and now there's a pin along the g
file and nothing is really helping
defend g2
oh this is white's idea
so g3
thanks for the bits whoever you are so
g3
um the pawn's still pinned
i have upon that fort but i can um i can
take it
if i take it white takes back and the
bishop defends upon
if i play h4
if h4 that actually allows g4 which is
crazy
so i'm actually thinking about bishop h4
here
trying to remember where my light sword
bishop is still on b7
yeah it's really a question how i i
exploit this uh
situation on the king side i think i'm
gonna play bishop h4
elegant h4 i'm attacking g
the g pawn now three times
it's only defended basically twice
with this bishop on battery thanks for
subbing
i'll try and express some some thank
yous afterwards
so knights on h2 pawn on g3 f2
queen cell and c2 i have pawns on each
five four ce2
oh oh that's one way to defend that's a
good move
i mean at some point i'd probably want
to sack
i was also thinking
some kind of knight f6
oh there's a cool idea
i don't want to play it yet though let's
play knight six horsey f6
well the still on a5 as well wow
so all the focus is on the king's side
and it's the type of position where you
usually want to play quickly but i'm
thinking about just kind of doing a
slow plan of rook like basically
doubling up rooks on the g
file hey it's v6
yeah it's a move so i
have to take back probably
oh the rooks on a1
uh cb6 c eats b6
c5 yeah it's getting really messy
not in my favor either
uh bishop stalin d3 queensland c2
okay
so i probably have to just yolo
the thought was to take on g3 with the
bishop and then play h4
and what else to do there's rook c8
which could be
probably not good though
there's also some like 95
which is crazy
i think i want to play knight d5
because i have knights on e7 and now f6
played knight d5 pawn d5 bishop d5
there's nothing really covering d5
because the knight went to e2
yeah let's let's play oh i have to
specify which knight
knight ed5 horsey eats d5
and the whole idea especially with
apollon g3
i'm not at all trying to win that
material
and she's sacking a a piece here for a
couple pawns but the whole idea is to
get the
lights for a bishop to control g2 and h1
and then basically suffocate the king
and try and checkmate before white meets
me
i'm not quite aware of the time
situation i assume i have like around
five minutes left
starting with 10 minutes or some
increments
we've both been taking some time
okay so the pawn is still on c5
queen is on c2
and it's just a mess mess of a position
basically mesopotamia he eats d5
yeah so that was expected so bishop d5
thanks for the bits i'm not sure if the
tts is uh this is working i could
may have not fully updated the settings
anyway okay let's try and stay focused
what just happened there the pawn's
still on c5
elephant eats a6 yeah i was aware of
that
um now the good news is the bishop is no
longer in the center but the bishop is
causing some havoc
so basically i have a knight two bishops
and two rooks to work with
um oh the knight's still on e2
so it's a question how my knight how
does my knight become relevant
there's some f3 move this bishop on e1
is actually really well placed
if i take
okay i'm going to try um this is only
hope i see bishop g3
elephant eats g3
so i'm sacking another piece
i'm really going all out like f eats g3
yeah g3 oh now the file's kind of open
for white
but the idea is h4 h4
um in others there's a ton of pressure
just with the pawns i have pawns on
on h3 h4 and f4 so i basically have two
pawns attacking g3
and the thing is pinned and the bishop
piercing through
along the long diagonal
i still have my knight on f6 white still
has this
tension with c5
c5 i think is still attacking both b6
and d6
randomly queen's on c2
right has a bishop on e1 and knight on
e2 and ch2 v6
yeah oh it's threatening it's writing
nasty things
well it's writing mate in two i'm pretty
sure
so i have no time to take but i do have
a move here
uh i think it's a useful move rook h7
rook h7 um
with it has an attacking purpose and a
defensive purpose
the defensive purpose is preventing
queen c7 which i think was a threat
it's also preparing the double up with
rook hg7
and then some kind of
g-file battery pin action
kebab thing
the problem is g and g3 is still covered
by white
white just has so many minor pieces too
white still has all the minor pieces
yeah white has the bishops on e1 a6 and
knights on e2 h2
and queen on c2
it's a lot more difficult when it comes
to blindfold chess when the position
gets
chaotic to keep track of everything
because
chunking is just more difficult when
pieces are on illogical squares
like this e1 bishop
or at least the bishop on e192 i can
just kind of see the relationship
pressuring lady a4
okay one wants to me me i don't know if
there's a threat with that move
i mean white definitely has a plan but i
think i have a move to
try and grab initiative
i don't have any checks
let's uh let's take on g3 hg3 h eats g3
okay bishop on d5
like i keep having to refresh like where
where all the pieces are
it's like i'm in um let's compare this
it's like i'm in a dark room and i have
a flashlight i can kind of shine it
on different areas of the board so
remember where things are
so bishop on d so what's relative what's
most relevant
i'm attacking the nylon h2
it works on g8 so i'm threatening some
discoveries
couple that with my not enough six i
might be threatening
g takes h2 king h2 rook g2
i don't know if it leads to elephant c8
wow one's being very tricky
um so i can take the knight and that's
double check
oh that's still on e2 as well
and yeah everything defends
so yeah white's being tricky white's
threatening
wait does white have a threat white
might not have a threat
even though that's such a devious move
let's um
okay first things first let's take on h2
danger
danger
expecting king takes
you what else to do
i guess big daddy f2 king f2 is legal
rook is rick g2 mate
wait the knights on e2
is rook g2 rook g2 might be mate knights
on e2 bishops on e1
rooks on f1 i have upon that f4
controlling e3 my bishop controls f3 and
defends g2
rook g the mouse slip
2 rook g3 no no no no
no no no no no no
lady a7 danger wait
okay seven rookies i really thought i
triple checked the keyboard
g3 no
i feel so broken at least i won the
queen
oh my time uh fg3
f eats g3 danger
do i win on time i won on time what is
this final position
lady big rook g3 big daddy f2
i i that was not uh not intentional
wow what the game though
also elegant c8
yeah i forgot my pawn was on h3 too big
are you calculating
h4 what a game
he mastered made in one no so the the
bishop controls a8
which i'm pretty sure my opponent maybe
didn't realize elephant
big daddy
elephant h4 that was a weird weird
finish
i mean like i even like i tried to lift
the blindfold to make sure i was
clicking two
and for some reason whenever i do that i
second guess myself
and then miss miss click uh
daddy f2 yeah this this was me it's so
funny
uh i'm assuming there's made after this
too
i did i i was thinking about night g4
but i i didn't
realize the bishop defense i i did see
this and i did see this
covering the mating ideas oh this could
have been like a fun windmill
g eats h2 danger i guess beats h2 the
time warning
was um was for my opponent not for me
no it was for me maybe i got below a
minute
i don't know
oh it's made in four where's the maiden
four
oh h2 is going to be mate yeah so kg1 h2
is mate
yeah i'm really not sure if i would have
found that
yeah i'll brainstorm some youtube titles
uh but chat says hi youtube
yeah thanks you two people for watching
i hope that was instructive
like how to play down the queen create
some chances
um like white should have been a bit
more aggressive
like leave the queen here and play c5
quicker and then
maybe i would play b5 and then white can
sack and break through
so
that was a very complex position around
here as well
yeah this was a blunder okay
thanks for watching people on youtube
hit subscribe
hit like and i'll see you in the future